[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening 19 children were shot dead
at school in ivalde texas yesterday
they were all under the age of 12
slaughtered in their classroom by an 18
year old maniac who just bought the guns
he used for his 18th birthday present
these children's parents took them to
school yesterday morning their young
hearts joyful with excitement for
another day of education and fun with
their friends
but they never went home and they're
never going home
and those parents will never recover now
from the loss of their children
they were slaughtered by this 18 year
old lunatic who was then shot dead by
police
in the deadliest school massacre since
sandy hook where 20 children of six
adults were killed in another senseless
tragedy that devastated the world that
was 10 years ago
and what's changed
well nothing is the staggering answer
america's endured more than 900 school
shootings
since sandy hook including 27 this year
alone
in fact there have been more mass
shootings in 2022 in america than days
of the year so far
some politicians like senator chris
murphy from connecticut where sandy hook
happened
can't understand why
what are we doing
why are you here
this isn't inevitable
these kids weren't unlucky
this only happens in this country
he's right whichever side of the gun
debate you're on
america has a uniquely hideous record
for gun deaths and mass shootings
against the world's richest countries
only in america should mean the
opportunity for any person to aspire to
be anything they want to be in the most
successful country on earth it shouldn't
be the mournful lament we hear every
time a maniac opens fire on innocent
children in a place that's supposed to
be happiest and safest
history doesn't have to repeat itself
but with mass shootings in america with
school shootings it does again and again
and again and the big question is why
steve kerr who's the coach of the golden
state warriors basketball team one of
the biggest names in u.s sport spoke for
many last night
since we left shooter on 14 children
were killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket
in buffalo we've had asian church-goers
killed
in southern california and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we going to do something
well it's a very good question isn't it
i understand his anger and passion not
least because his own father was killed
in a terrorist attack in beirut so he
understands pain and grief and loss
i also understand a few issues are as
impassioned or as divisive in america as
guns it's not for me as a non-us citizen
to tell americans the laws that they
should have
i learned the hard way after sandy hook
that a british accent shouting about gun
control to americans goes down about as
well as an american accent telling brits
to abolish the monarchy would go down so
let me say this instead
i understand and respect the
constitutional right of american people
to own guns under the second amendment
that was a right ratified by the supreme
court in 2008
but surely there must be some things
that all parties can agree on
opponents of new gun laws say they
wouldn't stop shootings because
criminals will still get hold of them
but by that logic why have any laws
against anything
we have laws against murder but we know
it won't stop all murders we just hope
it will reduce the number of murders
the shooter salvador ramos legally spent
five thousand dollars buying two ar-15
semi-automatic rifles and
375 rounds of ammunition just a few days
after his 18th birthday
and yet he couldn't have legally bought
a beer in texas for another three years
nor could he have bought a kinder
surprise chocolate egg anywhere in
america because they're banned over the
choking thread of the toys inside
you don't have to be pro or anti-gun
control to realize this is bafflingly
inconsistent
just as it seems absurd that there's no
law enforcing universal background
checks on all gun sales when 91 of
americans in the polls want them to
happen
and those background checks must include
all potentially relevant information
ramos was known to police after violent
arguments with his drug abusing mother
and firing bb guns and we now know he
posted his plan to attack a school on
facebook before carrying it out
the supermarket shooter in buffalo new
york peyton gendron was also 18 when he
murdered 10 black people in a white
supremacist rampage just 10 days ago he
bought his guns legally too
and was also known to police after
threatening to shoot up a school the
sandy hook shoot at adamanza was 20
and banning people from being able to
buy guns until they're 21
won't stop all young men like this
getting their hands on guns but
shouldn't we at least make it more
difficult for them
there were calls today for more armed
security at schools
we know from past experience of the most
effective tool for keeping kids safe
is armed law enforcement on the campus
senator cruz may have a point i don't
disagree with making schools more secure
but the texas shooter was engaged by an
armed school guard before he even got
inside
the guard was shot and ramos carried on
his attack
so the answer to these endless massacres
can't always just be more guards or more
guns which another leading cause of
death for u.s children overtaking car
accidents think about that
texas already has about twice as many
registered guns as any other us state
more than a million of them are
registered the guns didn't stop this
tragedy they caused it
it takes a mentally ill monster to gun
down innocent children
it's also monstrous to what you happen
time and again and do nothing isn't it
america is a magnificent country with
great people i've lived there and worked
for nearly 20 years
in the united states and i love the
place but the level of gun violence is
spiraling out of control the massacres
are getting worse and more frequent
it just can't go on like this
toxic partisan point scoring which
erupts after every one of these terrible
atrocities achieves nothing
nor do the thoughts and prayers of
people in the aftermath
nor do liberal celebrities screaming
abuse at law-abiding conservative gun
owners
as i said is for americans to resolve
this gun violence crisis not people like
me who are not american but all i will
say tonight is the bullet-ridden bodies
of those poor innocent children lie in
mortuaries
is that surely surely
doing absolutely nothing
to prevent this happening again
can no longer be an option
well next tonight a shameful day for
british politics
i would like to correct
the record to take this opportunity
not in any sense to absolve myself of
responsibility
which i take and have always taken
yes from a story about the truly
unimaginable suffering of ordinary
people to want about utter contempt for
them at the very heart of the british
government prime minister boris johnson
presided over a culture of disgusting
and deplorable disrespect for british
voters and for the laws that he had made
and told us to follow civil servants sue
grey's report into illegal lockdown
breaking parties at downing street would
finish any politician with an ounce of
shame but tonight the enduringly
shameless boris johnson staggers on
i want to begin today by renewing my
apology to the house to the whole
country
for
the short lunch time gathering on the
19th of june 2020 in the cabinet room
and the house will note that my
attendance at these moments
brief as it was
has not been found to be outside the
rules i had no knowledge of those
subsequent proceedings because i simply
wasn't there
and i have been as surprised and
disappointed
as anyone else in this house
as the revelations have unfolded
i believe that they were were work
events
uh it's they were part of my job a lot
of the stuff that i saw in the report uh
this morning uh you know was news to me
was it boris
it was news to you that there were
endless wild parties going on in your
home
under your nose some of them attended by
you
this is all the usual boris played but
more apologies
more insincere excuses
and then always a few laughs
anything he's really sorry about is the
fact he got caught
we know that boris johnson broke the law
he was fined for it by the police that
would have done in any normal prime
minister we already know that 83 people
got more than 126 fines for partying his
staff
when the country was told to stay home
and save lives by him and the same staff
we already know that johnson lied
including i believe to parliament that
always used to be a resignation offence
but will it be for him i doubt it
the devil is always in the detail
today's report's a rap sheet from
hypocritical hell
the lurid details about these parties
which happened in a place of work and in
the prime minister's own home home would
be shocking at any time the fact that
took place during a pandemic is almost
too outrageous to believe
this is some of what was said there was
excessive alcohol consumption by some
individuals one individual was sick
there was a minor altercation between
two other individuals so they were
vomiting and fighting as they broke
their own rules
helen mcnamara deputy cabinet secretary
attended for part of evening and
provided a karaoke machine
karaoke and this was the woman
specifically in charge of ethics at
downing street
a text message from the prime minister's
top adviser martin reynolds a complete
non-story but better than them focusing
on our drinks which we seem to have got
away with
well you didn't mr reynolds although in
a way perhaps you all have because
you're all still there aren't you
including your boss who said you know
nothing about any of this
and so it goes on
some members of staff says the report
drank excessively the event was crowded
and noisy a cleaner who attended the
room the next morning noted there was
red wine spilled on one wall a number of
boxes of photocopier paper
vandalism wine stains
some staff have witnessed it says or
been subjected to behaviors of work
which they had felt concerned about
multiple examples of a lack of respect
and poor treatment of security and
cleaning staff this was unacceptable you
think
your damn right is unacceptable to
absolutely kick him a teeth to all those
people he couldn't go and see their
loved ones as they died in hospital
the people at the center of the british
government showed a calculated contempt
for ordinary people not only in their
place at work but for the rest of us too
and most disgracefully there was a party
that went until way after four o'clock
in the morning on the very eve
of prince philip's funeral a funeral
where the queen
sat alone in her grief away from her
family
after losing the man she was married for
70 years
because she was following the rules
that everyone had been told to follow by
boris johnson
and his staff who just ignored them all
themselves to party until 4am
johnson's desperate defenders told us we
had to wait for the police investigation
before passing judgment so he did
and it was damning then they told us we
had to wait for sue grey's report before
passing judgment so we did and heard
that but it was damning too
boris johnson and his staff took the
public for idiots
brazenly breaking the rules that him
falls on the rest of us and then he the
prime minister lied through his back
teeth about it he should of course do
the honorable thing and resign
he doesn't know the meaning of the
phrase honorable thing
well for survivors and victims families
of the 2012 sandy hook massacre in
connecticut the attack at the rob
elementary school in texas brings up
chilling reminders of a very dark day in
american history scarlett louis's son
jesse was just six years old when he was
killed along with 19 other students and
six adults and scala joins me now
scholar thank you so much
for joining me i i thought of all of you
because i was on air at the time in
america at cnm when this happened uh it
was an absolutely harrowing story to
report on as indeed had been the similar
massacre at dunblane in scotland in the
mid 90s and in fact this morning i had
an email exchange of one of the mothers
of one of the children who died at
dunblane because
i recognized that for all of you uh
trapped in this appalling club of
mothers and fathers who've lost kids to
these school massacres
when another one happens it must take
you all right back
to the day that you lost your own
children is that what it was like for
you when you heard about this
absolutely pierce i i i was living the
experience right alongside all of those
parents
when they were waiting to get word
whether their child was going to be
found dead or alive those hours those
torturous hours
and then you know
my first thought this morning was
how they would wake up and and for one
split second forget
and then this crushing blow would come
down over them that
their child was dead that yesterday they
were planning
uh the summer fun and and today they're
going to have to start thinking about
writing an obituary they're going to
have to start planning for funerals and
it is
it was a gut punch to me and and so
incredibly painful and and honestly i
can't believe that i'm
standing here talking to you ten years
after the murder of my own son jesse at
sandy hook alongside 19 of his first
grade classmates and six educators and
now here we have another one after
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
school shootings later and of course
columbine 20 years before and we are
still hearing the same tired narrative
it is so frustrating
you know there's the saying that the the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing again and again and expecting a
different result you could switch this
round and say that with these massacres
in america and the school shootings the
definition of insanity is doing nothing
again again and again and expecting a
different result you know i knew after
sandy hook that if there was no change
at all
in the way that america was going to
respond to these massacres then
inevitably there would be more of them
i i felt the same way piers i i i saw
some movement but
we're always a step behind and the
frustrating thing is
these are preventable every single one
and we're reactive and as you said we do
the same thing over and over expecting a
different result it's the definition of
crazy that's why
after jesse's murder
obama flew in he was talking about gun
control and i realized that that had
failed uh obviously for sandy hook and
so i took a different approach i decided
to focus on the root cause of the pain
and suffering that leads to these events
and so in other words offering
schools homes and communities skills and
tools that they can use that help kids
face their hurt and pain be able to
manage it
live with it grow through it be
strengthened by it and flourish i think
that this is absolutely a hundred
percent
necessary it should be in every single
school
uh and and and i'm actually on my choose
love bus tour right now you caught me in
new hampshire
um uh working for governor sununu
traveling around the state
bringing love hope and healing to
communities here that we've been doing
through uh through the uh pandemic and
we will continue to do you do remarkable
work and it's very inspiring that out of
such an appalling tragedy you're able to
find the strength to do this and i
commend you for that i want to take you
back to what happened to your boy he was
six years old and he was an absolute
little hero because he was in the
classroom when the
the shooter adam lanza came in and his
gun jammed and your little lad jesse
shouted at his friends to get out of the
classroom which a large number of them
did i think eight or nine of the kids
got out and then he was shot dead uh a
absolute hero was that in keeping with
his character
absolutely absolutely that was jesse uh
and i i if he wasn't coming back as we
waited for those hours i knew that he
would have done something brave and when
the the shooter had shot his way through
the glass doors of sandy hook elementary
school he made a left
down the first grade hallway of course
he knew where that was because he had
attended that school
the principal and guidance counselor
were meeting with a parent they were
startled they opened the door to see
what
what the the
noise was all about they were gunned
down and then the shooter turned into
jesse's first grade classroom everyone
was scattered his gun actually ran out
of bullets at that time and during the
short delay that it took him to change
his clip
jesse called for his classmates to run
and he is credited with saving nine of
his classmates lives before losing his
own
no child should ever be asked to do that
in his in school i mean it is our
responsibility to keep our kids safe and
to address their mental health and
well-being and we have to start taking
that responsibility a lot more seriously
in fact we need to start making our kids
a priority
yeah i mean i it just seems to me that
one of the worst things about the
these
massacres certainly the last two and
sandy hook is the age of the people
doing this and there seems to be a
pattern of sort of disenfranchised young
kids 18 19 20
disconnected from society
who uh i think this one was addicted to
video games and so on which
i think also was the one at sandy hook
but what strikes me is completely
perplexing i think it does to many
people uh in america as well as outside
is that they none of them could have
bought a beer legally in any of the
states that they were living
they couldn't buy a kinder surprise
chocolate egg
but they can go and buy a semi-automatic
rifle
and this is what they do legally i mean
the last two massacres were committed by
18 year olds who bought guns perfectly
legally but they couldn't get a beer if
they wanted to it seems incomprehensible
to me that you would have a set of laws
where you can't get a beer but you can
buy a semi-automatic gun and go and
shoot up a school
actually what's really interesting to me
is that the brain
doesn't uh fully develop until you're
25.
so uh it becomes very frustrating and it
is appears it's the same story over and
over and over again
it is bullying it's disconnection it's
isolation it's loneliness it's a focus
on on activities that are singular
and it is a lot of hurt and pain and
suffering and it's kids that do not have
social and emotional competence they do
not have coping mechanisms they don't
have the ability to manage that pain so
it continues to grow into rage and all
they know to do because they don't know
that they have a choice is to take that
pain out on other people and
each and every one could be preventable
with
literally what we're doing now that is
why i am on the road and i want to tell
you too that i i have hope uh i was
addressing a high school today there
were 1400 kids this was a speak up event
that was organized in new hampshire our
strongest state for choose love because
of governor sununu understanding that
this is a really important piece for
school safety
and the kids knew that they needed help
they wanted to address their mental
health and so they literally
uh
created this idea and created the entire
day uh their their educators and
administration got on board and
supported them and so we talked about
what was going on in in a teenager's
life today there's so much i mean we
have we have these cell phones and we've
got 24 7 information that adults really
can't handle that our brains haven't
caught up to we have front row tickets
to the worst of humanity and we're not
giving our kids the skills and tools
that they need to manage
that trauma that's literally sitting in
their hand and so today i shared with
them some really life transforming and
life-saving skills that will help them
manage their pain not just today but
throughout their life and we know
through science is a pathway to
flourishing we need to do more of this
pierce scarlet i could not agree with
you more i think it's i think the
desensitization
of this generation of kids is a massive
problem i think it's driven by endless
exposure to shocking imagery and videos
and so on from social media shared
around you know they're seeing stuff in
real time happening minutes after it
happens whereas 40 years ago you would
never have seen it and i think it's a
it's a massive problem i'm i'm awestruck
by your courage and your inspiration to
be perfectly honest you know i remember
sandy hook so vividly you know maybe
upset just remembering it as i thought
about your boy and all the others um so
thank you for what you're doing because
we've got to try and work our way
through this and there's not a simple
solution but there's going to be there's
got to be a solution i'll i'll leave
i agree and i'll leave you with this
jesse left a message on our kitchen
chalkboard shortly before he went to
school and then later was murdered he
wrote three words nurturing healing love
now they were phonetically spelled
because he was in first grade and just
learning to write but i knew then and
there that if the shooter had been able
to give and receive
nurturing healing love the tragedy would
never have happened we know that someone
who loves and feels good about
themselves they're not going to want to
hurt themselves and they're not going to
want to hurt other people so that really
gave me my mission jesse gave me my
mission he uh he and his big brother jt
are examples for me for courage and so
i'm going to keep going because i truly
believe in my heart that this is the
solution and that we can reduce and
prevent the majority of suffering that
we're experiencing in our country and in
our world by choosing love yeah scarlet
i
couldn't put it better than you because
i can't put it better than you you've
just put it as well as it could be
expressed and i just want to end by
saying again how heroic your lad jesse
was that day he saved the lives of
so many of his little classmates and it
cost him his life but what an amazing
little hero he was and i wish you all
the very best with your campaigning keep
it up
thank you thanks pierce
they're remarkable people and they
belong to
the worst club you could ever be in
isn't it the club of the
parents who've
never seen their children again because
they got gunned to pieces at school in
these massacres well earlier we heard
that texas senator ted cruz the call for
more armed police officers to be
stationed at schools across the united
states joining me now someone who agrees
with that conservative radio host ben
ferguson ben you and i
have had a lot of fiery debates over the
years about gun control so i don't want
to have one of those with you because i
think i don't think they ever really
achieved very much and then when i watch
social media today everyone on all sides
of this debate blowing up uh emotionally
raging on both sides ever more
entrenched
what i want to try and do sure is try
and get to a place where we can at least
agree some things
and i just wonder you know you're a guy
from texas you're a father
when you heard about this
you're a gun owner and you support the
second amendment and i fully respect
that but when you heard about this
tragedy what was your sort of gut
feeling about this
i i think first it was
why in america do we not protect our
children our most vulnerable and most
valuable
by making sure that there's law
enforcement at every public school we
protect our president we protect our
senators we protect our governors we
protect our money at our banks we
protect the jewelry at the jewelry store
with armed guards guards but we don't
protect our children with armed guards
we can obviously afford it in america
there was an armed guard at the school
and he challenged he challenged the
shooting before he got in and he got
shot he got shot and disabled so you
have there was an armed guard there but
and there wasn't there was in the
buffalo street let me finish yeah but i
mean you do you know that that wasn't
let me
let me let me finish you you had two
different police officers that were
actually shot by this individual
yesterday and you had border patrol
agents that responded but you had an
open door to that school and if you have
security measures at a school the way
that many private schools do them in the
country they make sure that those
schools are locked and that someone
can't just randomly come in from the
outside
and that's part of the problem we don't
have enough police officers who
understand the lockdowns of a school to
protect the children from outside
individuals trying to get in and my
point is this we are supposed to be a
wealthy nation just like your your
country is as well we just spent 40
billion dollars to ukraine uh the people
that by the way are yelling about guns
right now the same people demanding we
send more guns to ukraine which i think
is very odd but we have to do a better
job of finding a consensus here and
saying you know you mentioned earlier
that the and he said some interesting
things
the coach of golden state a couple years
ago he came out in a very fiery comment
saying that he did not want to have
armed guards at schools and then today
he comes out with this very fiery
statement there's got to be some
compromise where parents can say okay we
all agree that our children are valuable
and we need to make sure that we have
mechanisms and we have the a way that we
do business every day at these schools
to protect these children same way
around presidential leaders i would
agree with you right i don't think
there's any option other than to protect
schools more given this appalling
tragedy and given what happened at sandy
hook and given the hundreds of school
shootings since sandy hook uh there's
got to be more security but just for the
record there was an armed police guard
at this school it's emerged tonight and
there was an armed guard and there was
no
questions are they finished to be
finished there was an armed guard at the
supermarket in buffalo so armed guards
alone
are actually not that effective it turns
out when you're facing a guy with full
body armor with a semi-automatic rival
who has the ability and advantage of
surprise it's very hard for one armed
guard so what do you do then do you then
have a number of arms at every school do
you have a whole sort of small army did
you turn the schools into militarized
bases what do you do
again this is where i have to disagree
with you my father's in law enforcement
and what do you do when you have one
police officer and you have a dangerous
situation you immediately call for what
backup and then when you are around
someone that's a world leader what do
you see you don't see one secret service
agent or one police officer when there
are people that you could know could
attack you have more than one and that's
what we have messed up in this country
we are not valuing the lives of our
children to the point where we should
say if you have a large campus and you
listen to the experts that talk about
how quickly a police officer can get
from one side of the campus the other
they all tell you the same thing you do
need multiple armed guards because it
takes too long
all right look so you're talking about
multiple armed guards let's come to the
other issue of the age that people are
legally allowed to get these
high-powered semi-automatic rifles
i don't understand how it can be illegal
to get a beer until you're 21
in most states in america but it's
perfectly legal to buy a semi-automatic
rifle or why it's you can't get a kinder
surprise chocolate egg anywhere in
america because you may choke on my
little toy but you can buy
hand guns i don't understand
that can you explain the logic behind
that
sure i think one of the problems you
have in this country and i think you
have around the world with lawmakers is
they're consistently inconsistent
with actually doing things that make
sense is it weird that you can buy a gun
at 18 but you can't buy
a beer until you're 21 of course it is
is it weird that you can go serve your
country and we'll train you how to
become a killer of terrorists around the
world but you can't drink a beer when
you come home from that trip that is
insanity the fact of the matter is
though it's not an age issue in this
country right now as much as we want to
obsess over it it's a lack of parenting
issue in this country that we have look
at what we see consistently look at the
man that we're talking about right now
he just turned 18. there were massive
warning signs that this person was
clearly mentally troubled he came to an
event and he had slashed his own cheeks
and said it was fun and he wanted to
feel the pain he had talked about
committing heinous crimes and violence
look at what happened in buffalo we know
the shooter there threatened to kill
people at his school we have the warning
signs you have a parent and grandmother
who had called the police on this
individual multiple times now think
about that from a parent
i agree but all your painting is an even
more inexplicable picture as to why
these kids who are clearly mentally ill
you have to be mentally ill to do what
they do mentally ill are able to just
wander into any gun stool perfectly
legally and buy semi-automatic rifles
but they can't get a beer uh look i've
got to leave it there
but it's a sad day
is it going to change if they're at 21
probably not that's
an arbitrary age is not going to fix
this if we want to fix this problem we
need to number one protect the schools
we should have bipartisan support on
that and two we need to make sure that
when law enforcement is called to
someone's house from a parent begging
for help for a child that clearly has
having massive problems that we have
mechanisms to stop them from actually
doing this yeah i think you need all of
that and then you need to stop deranged
young people being able to legally get
assault rifles and send me
semi-automatic rifles anyway ben we've
got to leave you there you know i want
to have a constructive ongoing dialogue
about this because it can't go on
america can't just keep waking up to
these tragedies it's it's just
heartbreaking for everybody you got
another whole series of families now
lives completely destroyed so at least
i'm sure we can agree this cannot go on
like it is doing nothing cannot be the
sensible humane option so we've got to
keep talking we've got to find points of
consensus i don't think shouting on
either side ever gets anywhere with
these debates so let's you know keep
talking come back again let's discuss it
and let's see if we can get to points of
consensus and try and help things
good to talk to you totally agree thank
you
john says the next another shameful day
of british politics will boris johnson
resign we'll debate that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well now we've got super great gaming
reporting to illegal lockdown busting
parties in downing street and frankly
there should be a resignation matter for
any prime minister particularly who's
been fined himself for breaking the law
that he set but apparently not for boris
johnson he discussed this as socialist
authority grace blakely and former
conservative mp louise mensch well grace
i read the report it's here 40 odd pages
of frankly
awful stuff
about a group of people arrogant
entitled brazenly ignoring their own
rules vomiting fighting
boozing even on the night before prince
philip's funeral and at the end of it
you just feel sickened and yet no one
seems to be taking any accountability
whatsoever least of all the person at
the top yeah i mean even um what this
report is which is just it's written in
kind of bureaucracies it's um fairly
kind of uh it's you know just explaining
what was going on even through all of
that you can still see
this is pretty damning stuff this would
be a clear resignation issue for any
other prime minister
the issue is of course is that it just
seems as though boris johnson has no
shame right he's seen over and over
again these allegations that have been
made against him these proven
allegations have been made against him
and he just thinks that he can
continuously kick the can down the road
and hope that he can distract the media
distract the rest of the conservatives
with something else maybe because he
doesn't he does always get away with it
louise are you going to continue to
defend the indefensible are you you
think that's it move on now
defend the indefensible peers your
problem is that you've got a smoking gun
right now but what you don't have is
boris johnson being the one that pulled
the trigger i have to wonder if we read
the same report because i went through
those 40 pages and it certainly did
sound a bit like animal house in number
10 or some kind of frat party that we
all had when we were 20 years old and at
college the problem that you've got and
that boris johnson's enemies have got is
that sue grey's report makes it clear
that for almost all of these dudes he
was in the room for a few minutes then
went on to announce what he makes clear
what it makes crystal clear is that he's
the boss it was all happening in his
house and workplace he was living there
throughout all this
and he surely should have
accountability as the person presiding
over this mayhem the idea that there
were literally scores of illegal parties
breaking the very rules that he was
setting with his team
and doing it in such a brazen manner
shameless manner at what point in the
old days people would fall on their
swords for far less than this
why hasn't boris johnson just said you
know what actually
this is just beyond the pale i know what
people were sacrificing in in the
country and i'm going to i'm going to
resign
that it's not the decent thing he's got
he's got no
reason to resign far from being scores
of parties let's get this straight there
was eight parties in fact for which how
many more do you want
issued eight well whatever it's not
scores it's it's
you say that he lives and works there he
lives in the private residence about the
flat he didn't hear this stuff going on
he didn't come down and say turn down
the music
i've been in launcher the street many
times you can he of course he knew what
was going on and by the way apparently
he knew about the friday night party
every every friday everyone if you live
in an investigation
exactly what's going on you don't have
to read the long and boring report the
boris johnson deliberately kicked down
the road uh you know as long as he did
to hope that by this point there will be
something else for us to talk about you
don't have to go through all of those
very very clear allegations you don't
have to count the number of parties
everyone knows because this is
who thinks that he is above the law who
has no shame in making these laws and
then breaking them himself but the real
issue here and the issue that this is
exposed the issue that this government
has repeatedly exposed by admiring
itself in scandal after scandal after
scandal is that there are no mechanisms
in this country for holding our
elections to account i agree we have
parliamentary sovereignty fine that's
the way that this westminster system
works we're supposed to also have checks
and balances there are supposed to be
mechanisms that you can use to force
people who have done something wrong to
step down and not just rely on my point
my point to take them out i agree my
point would be you shouldn't have to
force boris johnson to step down but
actually in the old days a prime
minister who was convicted of breaking a
law he'd set
and had all this members of staff doing
this kind of thing they would just
resign but you can only rely on that
piece when you're talking about someone
who actually has shades and think that
things you know
but like
you made your point you think it's all
nonsense overblown he hasn't done
resigned for i get it i just think
you're completely wrong gotta leave it
there sorry please
committee thank you
yeah i know i've read it if you can't
resign over this i don't know what you
resign over i dread to think frankly
thank you both very much for your time
i'm censored next supermodel kate moss
takes the stand in the depth third trial
a friend janice dickinson will join me
live after the break after the
sensational developments today
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well the courtroom theatrics of johnny
depp and amber took another dramatic
turn today as depths former lover kate
moss the supermodel gave evidence from
her home in gloucestershire she made a
very brief appearance specifically to
testify that she was never pushed down
the stairs by debt contrary to rumors
resurfaced by amber heard in the case
two weeks ago
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs and i
swung at him did mr depp push you in any
way down the stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
i'm joined by sid model and a friend of
kate moss janice dickenson janice great
to have you on the show and you know kay
and johnny well um i thought it was a
very big moment in this trial because
amber heard had tried to use this
story which everyone thought was true
about johnny depp hurling kate moss down
the stairs as evidence this is what he
does and why she feared for her own
safety and there was kate moss who never
ever speaks in public so it's sort of
fascinating popping up purely for a few
minutes just to say
actually that story is completely untrue
and he never did anything like that to
me in our relationship what did you make
of it
i think
just from personal experience knowing
when kate moss was indeed the girlfriend
of johnny depp he was the boyfriend i
was on a flight
from
virgin islands to st barts and the both
of them had clearly been drinking as i
was clearly drinking on this air flight
and he was a total gentleman to her
and he was a total gentleman to me and
i've
ran into johnny depp several times in
los angeles
uh you know after after happy hour has
like long set
his son has said on happy hour he's he
was never violent towards anyone and as
far as amber heard saying that um she
had been
tossed down flights of stairs or or
beaten up by johnny depp or anything
like that i don't believe it in for one
new york city second i mean look look
what happened between the two of them
she severed his fingertip off right i'm
sorry
i mean i i'm going to say janice i've
watched the whole the whole thing from
time to time uh the clips and so on
we're just increasing kind of revulsion
really it's like the worst dirty linen
ever washed isn't it
don't you feel dirty watching this trial
i mean i have been watching it like this
but i'm planted to it at night and this
is this is a big thing here in los
angeles this trial
and
i'm opposed to amber heard
for my very own personal reasons about
women's rights as you know i was raped
by bill cosby uh during the cosby trials
and i went up against this monster and
testified for andrea constance on her
behalf well here i would i would be
ready to testify for johnny depp that
amber heard
had a had a fledgling career when she
first met when she first did the rum
diaries with johnny depp yeah johnny
depp is this mega superstar i think the
other thing janice i think i think the
bottom line with this is i think that um
kate moss today in a very powerful few
minutes may have completely swung this
back johnny depp's way because she
nailed a lie that amber heard was trying
to use i've got to leave it there janice
i'm sorry we run out of time but thank
you very much well thank you i'm a big
fan piers big fan of yours thank you
thank you very much appreciate it
bye on center next we pay tribute to
those 19 children and two teachers who
were tragically killed in the deadliest
u.s school shooting for a decade
we started this show tonight with the
story of the 19 children who were shot
dead at their school in valdez texas
these are those children they were all
under the age of 12 they were taken with
two of their teachers i want to take a
moment now to tell you the names and
ages of every single one of these
victims so that we can all fully
comprehend what has happened here
the syria garcia was eight her granddad
described him as the sweetest little boy
i've ever known
javier javier lopez was ten
he was bubbly and loved to dance
amory joe garcia was ten her grandmother
said she was super outgoing and a
teacher's pet
anabella guadalupe rodriguez was 10
years old she was an exemplary student
nevaeh bravo's cousin says she's flying
with the angels above
ten-year-old ellie lugo's father
described her as a doll
and was the happiest ever
rogelio torres was ten his cousin said
it breaks my heart to say my rogelio is
now with the angels
tess marie mata's sister called her a
precious angel
lexi rubio was 10 and was described as a
bright light in everyone's life
jose flores was 10 and loved to laugh
and have fun
jc carmelo lua velenos who was 10 and
jayla nicole seguiro who was 11 were
cousins
the mother of jayla said of them fly
high my angels
ten-year-old mattie giuliana rodriguez's
cousin described her as a sweet smart
little girl
ten-year-old alithea romero's dad said
she loved to draw and wanted to be an
artist eleven-year-old miranda mathis's
cousin said we loved you dearly i'm so
sorry this happened
mckenna elrod was ten her sister told us
all to hug her loved ones tight tonight
and tell them that you love them
elijah cruz torres was ten her family
said she didn't want to go to school on
the day of the shooting
ten-year-old jackie cazarez her little
sister potala line that she was sorry
she forgot to say good morning today
two teachers also died 46 year old iama
garcia who taught at the school for 24
years and had four children along with
44 year old mother of one
eva morelias
i took my 10 year old daughter
to school today
it was just an art exhibition day with
all her friends they were all 10 11 the
same age as these kids
that were slaughtered yesterday in texas
i can't even imagine
what those parents are now going through
other than i've spoken to sandy hook
parents to dumb blame parents i have
some idea but it's the ultimate
unimaginable horror and once again i
just say
to america a country i love
do something about this please for the
love of god we have got to stop kids
being slaughtered in their classroom
that's all for us tonight
justified on behalf of the actor in his
libel trial against ex-wife amber heard
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you